listen to geralt speak and see if you
notice anything different
about the way he talks running low on
patience
got some other things on my mind looking
for a woman
recognize me from master dandelion's
balance 2
came to look for you crocs worried
taking you home need to find your friend
could go with a kobold's eyes
but the creatures are sentient rather
not gouge one's eyes out
i've played a ton of the witcher 3 and
cyberpunk 2077.
i've witnessed nearly every possible
outcome in geralt's adventure and i'm
already a hundred hours deep in
cyberpunk 2077.
one thing that's always stood out to me
about cd projekt red's characters is how
they talk
they almost always chop off the
beginning of their sentences
before we get into it make sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things cyberpunk
now let's run that geralt montage again
running low on patience
got some other things on my mind looking
for a woman
recognize me from master dandelion's
ballads too
came to look for you crocs worried
taking you home notice how in every
single one of these scenes
geralt drops the subject pronoun for
those who haven't opened an english
textbook recently like yours truly
subject pronouns are i you he she they
and so on
instead of saying something like i don't
think that's a good idea
geralt says don't think that's a good
idea
back in 2015 when i played the witcher 3
i just chalked it up to the fact that
geralt's a badass and badasses used
their words sparingly
by cutting off the subject pronoun of
most of his sentences
he just sounded well more badass that's
the problem
it was more however when i got my hands
on cyberpunk 2077 i noticed that many
characters also speak like geralt
even keanu reeves character johnny
silverhand
sure hope so b now i think it's safe to
say that johnny is a badass as well but
hearing keanu reeves cut off the
beginning of his sentences
sounded off imagine if john wick said
they cannot
back instead of i'm thinking i'm back
it just doesn't feel right johnny
silverhand isn't the only character in
cyberpunk 2077 that speaks like this
though
nearly every character does didn't
answer my question now
did you looking for evelyn parker know
if you see her
come on no place we can talk where ears
won't prick up to listen
i'm stepping outside can't smoke in here
it doesn't matter who they are where
they come from or what they do
they frequently drop the subject pronoun
at the beginning of their sentences
sure we could pin it all on the fact
that everyone in night city is a badass
and therefore needs to use as few words
as possible but the real reason might be
a bit more complicated than that
this way of speaking is actually common
in the polish language and according to
cyberpunk 2077's quest director whose
name i'm going to butcher matej
tomaskovich
cyberpunk 2077 script was written in
polish
and then translated into english
all right brace yourself for a brief
lesson in verb conjugation
polish is what's known as a pro-drop
language short for pronoun dropping and
is one of the many languages where
subject pronouns like you she
i or they are regularly omitted in the
case of polish verbs are conjugated
according to the subject which often
makes the subject pronoun
redundant in standard english verbs are
mainly conjugated for tense rather than
subject
i played you played she played or i will
play you will play
she will play or they will play i wombo
he she me the main exception is in the
third person present tense you'd say he
plays
rather than he play but generally
speaking you can't
automatically know what the subject of
the sentence is just from the verb form
used
in polish however conjugated verbs match
both the person
first person second person or third
person and the number
singular or plural in other words the
verb form automatically tells you
whether the subject of the sentence is
me we you she he and so on meaning you
don't need the actual pronoun to be
understood
i don't speak polish but i do know some
spanish and it works basically the same
way
so to avoid butchering polish here's
some spanish conjugation to show how
this works
hablar means to talk in spanish as you
can see there's a different form of the
verb
depending on the subject and whether
it's singular or plural
hablo by itself means i talk because of
this you don't need these pronouns
unless you really want to emphasize the
subject
compare that with english where there
are only two ways to conjugate to talk
in the present tense talk or talks
english is not a pro-drop language and
most of the time we do need subject
pronouns in order to make sense
or just to sound natural there are
examples of pronoun dropping in english
though you might say sorry instead of
i'm sorry for something minor or you
might say love you instead of i love you
to certain people
we almost always drop the subject
pronoun you from commands like
clean your room but to drop the subject
pronoun regardless of the situation like
the characters in cyberpunk 2077 do
just sounds unnatural to the
english-speaking ear even if you can
understand from the context what the
character means
what's more interesting is that dying
light is a zombie free-running game
developed by polish studio techland
doesn't do this this is most likely due
to the fact that dying light was written
in collaboration with an american
novelist named dan
jolly here's a scene from the beginning
of dying light
all right taken care of piece of cake
what else you got for me well
let me think raheem you are just smart
enough to be dangerous you know that
omar told me about your plans for the
nest explosive charges
really what explosives okay please say
that
you can't tell a convincing lie to save
your life i know what i'm doing
yeah you think you can't die you're not
my mom no
i'm not our mom's dead so you might want
to be a little nicer to me since i'm the
only family you have left
especially now that amir is gone you're
jade right
right i just wanted to thank you for
what you did for me and tell you how
sorry i am for your loss
i owe you and a mirror in my life yeah
you do you want to return the favor
keep my [ __ ] brother from killing
himself
no explosives raheem as you can see
for most of these sentences the subject
pronoun hasn't been dropped so in
cyberpunk 2077 and the witcher 3 the
dialogue style could be a result of a
more literal translation from polish or
it could very well be a stylistic choice
to make the characters sound cooler or
edgier
is this a good way to write dialogue
though i don't really know
i was taught that punchy natural
sounding dialogue is the way to go
it's simple we uh kill the batman
cutting out words certainly makes
dialogue more punchy but does it sound
natural personally i thought that way of
speaking fit geralt really well
he's a man of few words so dropping the
subject pronoun whenever possible made
sense for his character
even if it wasn't intentional maybe it's
due to the different accents in the
fantasy setting
but generally i only notice when geralt
drops subject pronouns
in cyberpunk's case though i find it
pretty distracting maybe it's because i
was born and raised in california and i
know people don't and
probably won't ever talk like that but
hey you might feel differently if so let
me know in the comments below
and for more cyberpunk 2077 make sure to
subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
so
[Music]
you